okay we're back I think in the public
domain we've had a conference with the
aliens we can uh talk about C security
and a bit more knowledge so next item is
item seven which is the uh procurement
update about star which
is line and
Elizabeth are you both doing it or yeah
I'll move out to your way
around
don't know I see
B
[Music]
assist director delivery for Star
um H good evening I'm line cots the
director of Star
procurement okay so um our presentation
today is an a star update we come once a
year to the audit committee uh By
Request um so this is our update so um
since we were last here which was around
this time last year um we have um gained
two new partners so um we were
originally 4 GM um Partners but now
we've taken on St Helen's Council and
nossle Council as our fifth and sixth
partners of star that was last
October um this is all about Trafford so
our Trafford achievements so this is
something that we pull together on an
annual basis so this is based on
2223 um and this is the work that we've
done as your procurement delivery
service um in terms of efficiencies in
2223 uh we delivered over 1.4 million
pounds worth of efficiencies that isn't
just Revenue savings and that can be
taken directly from budgets that's a
combination of Revenue cashable um cost
avoid and savings and and uh Capital
Savings as well so we we pull them all
together in into one pot um also with
social value um we um achiev
47.1% social value return on the
contracts that we put out for traffic
Council in
2223 um sorry that's the accumulative
over four years I always forget that
that figure um yes so we launch social
value is everyone's business and I know
we've talked to you um as a committee in
the past about social value is
everyone's business so we launched that
back in
2019 um and we have tracked the social
value secured through procurements since
then um and yes traffic is
47.1% um
76.4 2% of spend um with Trafford spend
is retained within GM um and
49.7% of that um is retained within uh
Trafford that is in 2223 so we monitor
your local spend as well um compliance
is
91.5% in 2223 so that is what a piece of
work that we do on um a monthly basis
where we review the contracts register
so all the contracts that we've put in
place um uh against the spend so we get
spend data direct from your systems um
and we do that analysis so 91.5% of
those contracts in 22 23 were on the
contracts
register
okay and this slide is just a pictoral
um graph of the data that I've just
shared with you around uh social value
local spend and the
91.5% verified
spend moving a bit closer so this is
what we have ratified around quarter 1
for 2324 so this is um a dashboard that
we take to our board and Joint Committee
on a on a quarterly basis um so as of
quarter 1 22 23 24 um we had 163
collaborative contracts in place um we
switched around the non-verified spend
because we wanted to drive Improvement
and performance so um rather than it be
91.5 um verified we wanted to focus on
the non-verified spend and our Target
for non-verified spend is to get that
below
5% um so Trafford currently at at
quarter 1 we're sitting at 7.4% so
there's some work that we need to do
around the spend and uh the contracts
register to to drive that
improvement over on the other side the
community side um social value is
45.9% which is a slight drop from the
end of quarter four last year and local
spend again
42.6% which again is a slight drop for
for the end of the year but what we
obviously we measure this on a quarterly
basis and we're driving improvement
towards the end of this
year in terms of our compliance data um
so that's 7.4% that I mentioned um we
are undertaking some analysis work um to
look at individually what isn't
compliant who isn't compliant um and
what we can do about that so sometimes
it's just it's it's um a data lag you
know but you know before it's gone on
the contracts register we've spent the
money but it's not gone on the contracts
register so we want to move to improve
that and and make that a quicker uh
process and then we want to identify if
there's any Trends within that analysis
as well which we will share directly
with our board representative who is s
Salah in terms of exemptions for quarter
one there was just one exemption so an
exemption is exemption to our contract
procedure rules um so where a um
directorate can't follow the rules for a
certain reason they've got justification
for it they put through an exemption so
there was one in quarter one and that
was for the gd3 bus stop improvements
for 17 just over
177,000 again in terms of Trafford
achievements I think this is my last
slide and I'll hand over to to Lorraine
just want to talk about the roots to
Market so what we do on an annual basis
as well is look at the activity that
we've delivered for each of our partner
councils um so for
2223 we um undertook 42 call offs for
raford uh there was 21 exemptions um
there were 62 which are uh risk-based
sourcing that were we classed as low
risk or medium risk um those are the
contracts that we um Can can work with
local providers on and um Target local
providers um we had nine above threshold
tenders and we had nine highrisk risk
based souring procurements as well the
the rest of that slide is around the
focus for 23 24 we're we're just in
quarter four of 23 24 so we will uh we
will pick up 2425 next time thank
you thank cute Elizabeth um okay I don't
want to give you a theory lesson on
three lines of Defense but it was quite
interesting listening to colleagues
earlier about looking at this from a
risk perspective and looking at it from
in terms of how we manage the risk of
procurement for you um this has been a
request from a couple of the other audit
committees that we worked to in the
other councils within the star family
that they wanted to understand what you
know what does star do other than
obviously deliver performance outputs
efficiencies and indeed look at
compliance so this is just what the most
simplest slide I could find for you um
to actually talk you through what what
we do in terms of those different
elements of first line Second Line third
line of defense um and equally how we
integrate with your senior management
team within Trafford and how we work
with audit committees um in this
instance and obviously sometimes we can
be called to scrutiny as well so I've
just move on to the next slide to give
you a little bit more detail so what
sort of risks do we think about within
star I have to turn this way I can't
read my slide but um so the sorts of
things we're looking at at the moment we
all know there's a global financial
crisis taking place and we know how
that's playing out within the UK one of
the most incredibly hard things we have
to do at the moment is deliver savings
for you um every Council in country is
is under immense pressure um budget
setting is getting harder and harder
year on year and obviously the demand on
my team to actually um realize savings
for you is becoming more challenging we
had a session this morning with with the
whole team and we were talking about
this to explore how we can change our
approach are we measuring the right
thing are we reporting on the right
thing and actually challenging ourselves
because what we do at the moment is when
we're looking at saving we look at the
historic cost of your contract and then
we say when we bring a contract through
the procurement process and we award and
we we obviously have an award criteria
which looks at price it looks at quality
and it looks at social value and what
we're seeing now is the price on most
contracts are considerably higher from
your historic spend so immediately that
gives me a problem because I'm can't
report a saving or a cost reduction um I
think the very simple example I used
this morning with my team is you know
think about toilet rolls and and forgive
my my example but you can go into an
Aldi and a little and price match you
can go into a Saints as a tesc and you
can price match but actually all of
those shops even the ones that have
given good quality but lower prices
their prices have still gone up so it's
very very difficult when you're dealing
with an economic crisis to actually try
and deliver a saving when you're looking
at his historic spend and all of the
prices of all the things we buy
personally and professionally have
clearly gone up some some way um I'll
pick a couple of others out for you um
section 114 risk we all know what's in
the press in terms of councils
nationally um in in the the phases of
bankruptcy um we work closely with
Graham and the finance colleagues to
actually make sure that we're doing our
bit in terms of actually efficiency
through star um obviously we've talked
about savings but actually what else can
we do in terms of the added value piece
um efficiency can come in many ways
obviously looking at the price of the
contract and cost is important but
actually I have a budget how can I
reduce my budget and spend equally how
can I sell Services which we do do inst
stall we sell services to a number of
other public sector bodies across the
country and we bring income in as of
quite considerable sums so my job is to
reduce the cost of star to increase the
income of star and and the long term
ambition is to bring more efficiencies
in order that star costs less for the
council in terms of your annual fee that
you pay to us to to run the operation um
another quick one let me pick another
one out um climate emergency is a good
one and I think it's something that we
we don't always think about in
procurement terms um we started on a
rigorous campaign to build social value
into procurement and we now put a 20%
waiting into the evaluation so we have
price quality and social value part of
social value could look at how we
challenge biders to obviously firstly be
from our local doorstep in Trafford um
and we've had some very good results
that Elizabeth has shared with you
earlier in terms of that local spend
performance and retaining traffic's
money within either Trafford or greater
Manchester and Anna will say that star
is the best in the country in terms of
that retention so we're definitely doing
something right but when we look at the
wider agenda and and the fact that our
councils have declared climate
emergencies what are we doing towards
actually bringing Net Zero bringing um
your scope three emissions which are the
emissions that contractors produce as a
result of the contract that they may be
delivering for you so very quick example
we have delivery vehicles that bring
things to the council so you know what
we're trying to do is to say how through
procurement can we help to manage
mitigate or reduce that risk in terms of
that carbon production we know we've got
goals within greater Manchester in terms
of that 2038 Target been zero and what
we want to do is work with you through
procurement to say how do we manage that
risk and how do we make sure that our
suppliers our biders who are actually
coming to the market and actually
tendering for work how are we
challenging them to actually commit to
Net Zero proving they've got a carbon
action plan actually looking at how we
apply that in terms of potentially past
fail in the future so what I want to see
is biders coming who are actually
practicing the principles the values and
helping us with with management to such
risks like climate
emergency just moving back to the three
lines um so here is just a list really
of a number of examples of how we work
for you and with you um in terms of
making sure that these defense
mechanisms are in place so if you look
at your first line we have escalation in
Star um we've got quite a rigorous
regime of where you know again talking
to the colleagues that were in in the
room earlier we have escalation so
people don't immediately come to me with
when there is an issue it goes through
the chain of command we look at the risk
and actually think about at what point
do we need to escalate this into the
host authority of Trafford or indeed to
one of our partner organizations we have
internal control measures so we have
something called a quality management
system and what we've done is we've
built this gatekeeper role because what
my role is and my team's role is to
actually ensure that we check what your
officers do are they following
compliance are they actually following
due process and procedure and actually
what is the escalation and and result of
that risk if we identify that somebody
is trying to bypass those processes
moving into second line um another quick
couple of examples um Financial controls
one of the things we do is when we start
a procurement exercise your offices
within your organization have to do
something called a a project initiation
document a PID and within that we
capture budget information we get that
verified from Finance colleagues at the
beginning of the process and we also
check things like key decision because
we have had not in this Authority but in
in one of our neighbors um issues in the
past where key decision processes and
due processes haven't been followed and
that was actually picked up by one of
our audit colleagues so we are your
Gatekeepers we are here to not just run
compliant procurement for you and try
and secure best value what one of our
key roles is to actually help to
administer and control behavior um I'll
just whiz on unconscious of time um so
what do we do to manage these risks um
Mark sits on a collaborative audit group
obviously we've just welcomed our two
new audit colleagues from St Helens and
NOS be into that group um it isn't a
shared service it is a collaborative
which has been formed since star was
formed 10 years ago this month
incidentally and um I think Mark would
concur that that has been incredibly
helpful because firstly rather than as
being audited four times six times on
the same thing what we do is we have a
shared audit plan across the partner
organization
so Mark's team will be given a couple of
audits to do and so on and so forth and
we share that learning across the six
partners and it's incredibly effective
in terms of that relationship that
sharing and and actually you know
working together and collaboratively
across other
organizations um we contribute to the
annual governance statement where
required we have external audit links um
and we also Link in with um colleagues
from cabinet office central government
in terms of being very close to
procurement policy procurement
regulations most of you will probably be
aware that we've got a new procurement
act which we hope we will be deploying
and and starting to use towards the back
end of this year but that also brings a
lot of change change in Behavior
practice compliance transparency it puts
more onus on on us helping you as the
council and all other councilors to
actually ensure that business
communities can see what pipeline of
procurement opportunities are coming up
there's a big Drive there particularly
around smmes and and local businesses um
and vcss to actually have better access
to Tender opportunities and more
importantly to to support them to make
those processes simpler um in order to
enable them to Bid and Win um moving
down Senior Management you'll know Sarah
Salah um is our board representative um
we also have um senior leadership groups
that we attend um so we have a very
close working relationship so I always
say to people we we are are the council
we just happen to be six councils and we
carry many badges to get into various
buildings but you know we are the
council we're not external we're not a
contractor we're on your payroll and and
you know sometimes people treat us as
though we are slightly different because
we just work very very differently
because we're a
collaboration um another couple of
things um we've got a board um and a
joint committee um The Joint Committee
of the moment is councelor Patel as the
representative and I see councelor
accordingly and councelor but at the end
who have both previously been on our
joint committee so glad to see you both
this
evening um just a forward look really
what's the focus moving forwards well
I've mentioned that we've got the new
procurement regulations and act coming
into play hopefully at the end of this
year um and we did have a national
procurement policy statement that was
launched back in
2021 so what we've done Elizabeth taking
a lead on this is we've always
benchmarked star against any policy that
comes out from government so in 2021 we
regulated ourselves against the elements
of that um mpps in order that we knew
where are we and where do we need to be
so we always try and be ahead of the
curve in terms of um making sure that
we've got that preparedness so when we
cross the line hopefully in October and
the ACT is is in use I think is the
phrase and we're W waiting for secondary
legislation at present but let's be
optimistic that that will start to
happen in October but what we want to is
to make sure you are ready because there
are some big demands on transparency and
more information being out there in the
public Arena um and that's going to take
some work from the whole of the councils
elements of the councils as well as on
Star procurement um performance is key
the leftand Box we've talked about local
spend compliance collaboration
efficiencies my task at the moment is to
work with my starboard with officers
like gra and Sarah in Trafford to
actually say are we measuring the right
things
are we actually truly evidencing
Improvement and performance um because
we've had that framework for quite a
number of years now and you know as the
climate change is where where I started
when I was speaking um it may be that at
the moment we have to look at things
quite differently so I think it's
important that we measure performance
because that's the way that you know
that I'm moving you on and hopefully
moving you in the right direction in
terms of
improvement um just pick another one out
the business plan we have for Star
expires this year 2020 24 and I think
that aligns quite neatly with um
trafford's corporate plown I believe is
under review this year and I know that
you did have a council peer review back
in October of last year and again what
we try and do even dividing ourselves by
six we try to immerse ourselves within
the corporate family of Trafford because
we are your employers um or employees I
should say and equally it's really
important that we understand each
Council what your priorities are what
you need from us and how we need to
build your procure for you as an
organization as well as cross the Star
Family the last slide I'll refer to is
just the bottom one which is around how
we work across greater Manchester um
we've done a lot of work with colleagues
from the other councils and the combined
authority to look at social value in
particular to say what is important for
the region because whilst you know I
know we six hats and across two regions
it's making my job even harder but
what's important is that we understand
the Collegiate approach across grating
Manchester in terms of priorities so
things around re living wage and I know
this there's been um a lot of work in
traed around this agenda um we want to
look at how we can get biders to become
real living wage obviously we've got to
balance the cost implication with with
some of that we want biders to be
signing up to the greater Manchester
good employment Charter because you as a
council or a supporter of the such
Charter so actually why shouldn't our
biders actually practice the values that
you have within Trafford um inclusivity
diversity so looking at the makeup of
the businesses that actually come and
bid because actually what you want ises
BCS local businesses winning because if
we can retain your pounds in your burrow
your burrow will become more vibrant um
I was just doing some work with some
Irish people this morning um who are
actually Keen to look at how um Irish
companies can collocate and um they were
asking you what what's the priority for
Trafford and I know spoke to the leader
a number of months ago and and we were
talking about obviously with the new
ution deal your priority here is to
firstly let's get your businesses to to
survive with what they're dealing with
at the moment and secondly can we get
them to thrive and thirdly how do we
encourage more businesses within the
bough to actually be collocated or
located within the bough so we're always
looking at how we can help with that
diversity piece to actually bring more
local activity and make that a success
and needless to say number six on that
list is carbon reduction we've just
actually commenced a pile it with stock
Council on looking at car um carbon
emissions from um that what they call
their scope three and contracted spend
and hopefully once we've got that launch
we will want to roll that type of
approach around um the other five star
councils so there's a lot of work that
we we do individually for you as
Trafford we work as a star family we
also work with the GM family now as if
we've not got enough to do we've got a
Liverpool City region to tackle as well
but hopefully you can see that we're
building on the success of star we've
learned a lot in 10 years and counselor
but I think you were here right at the
beginning of star being fored before me
um you know we've come on a long way and
you know there is strength in numbers it
means we can buy cheaper toilet rolls
together um so you know there's some big
work ahead but hopefully you will see
that the journey over the last 10 years
has been
successful happy to take questions chair
thank
you
broy thank you for presentation really
fascinating you covered an awful lot in
a short period of time so my question
just wanted to focus on a couple of
things you mentioned on the example of
climate change and carbon
reduction one of the things that came
across from the previous presentation
was how important Communications is so
something like carbon reduction and you
mentioned vehicles that are used within
procurement some of the op take of the
alternative Vehicles is often dependent
on the companies and the individuals
kind of believing it's worth their while
having a vehicle that has lower carbon
emissions like electric vehicles for
example so I want to ask you how you do
your Communications around working
towards the carbon deduction so that's
one question I've got second one but
I'll wait to see you want chair me to do
my second one now or later
okay so the second question is around
your partners because it's quite um
intriguing and interesting to hear about
the social value and how you're
targeting that and that's obviously a
really good thing for people in the in
this
area you didn't mention Health as a
thing so one of the biggest employers
obviously are the NHS in um great
Manchester the um there's some you know
very large trusts NHS within great
Manchester and I wondered in terms of
procurement and Joint procurement how it
works to have like the kind of joint and
local procurement and local social value
within sort of the NHS Partners as
well thank you chair I'll take those in
order if I'm a councelor Bry um firstly
in terms of communicate communicating um
our commitment really and how we can use
procurement as a vehicle to move um the
next zero agenda forward particularly
with our great Manchester the target of
of being Net Zero by 2038 for me at the
moment it work because I feel nationally
I think procurement is behind in this
particular Arena and what we've got to
do is get ahead of it because we
shouldn't be contracting with people I
don't think that can't actually demon
straight some form of commitment there's
always a risk with that because if
you're looking at the smaller medium
Enterprises out there if you're looking
at the volunteering Community set to
businesses and Enterprises out there
that quite often we can put barriers in
so we have to be careful and think about
the bar
of what the ask is and are we actually
starting to then exclude our small and
medians and volunteering Community
sectors because actually they're the
bread and butter of the business
communities that I think we all want to
grow so I think there's a risk um I
think the important thing for me at the
moment is that we actually communicate
by signaling to the markets that this is
becoming important to us so by asking do
you have a carbon action plan can you
upload copy of your carbon action plan
do you monitor your scope through
emissions actually will you share your
Baseline with us and actually will you
upd is in 12 months time to show that
you've actually reduced them so what
we're doing at the moment is do this
signaling piece of work in order that
business communities understand what's
coming around the corner because that's
really important because we've got
support to support businesses to
mobilize so that's how I think we
communicate in that arena in terms of
Partners a really good question um
people have asked me you know why have
you gone after Liverpool City region
when there's 10 councils in Greater
Manchester um really good question I
probably haven't got a firm answer on
that but you tend to work Coalition the
Willing we have worked with a number of
councils within greater Manchester and
the NHS we do work for Northern Care
Alliance on an ad hop basis to name one
of the um health organizations we are
currently working with very Council on a
long-term as La we're actually just um
scoping a piece of work for alen Council
so we do look at our neighbors my
priority has always been great at
Manchester now I've just got to put my
priority um jointly into Liverpool City
region because there is a demand there
and those two councilors have actually
been working with star on a longterm SLA
for for a number of years so for me you
know sharing that love and sharing that
the practice is really important to just
answer the question on why why AR the
health people in the gang um what we've
done is we we've looked at that
Elizabeth haven't way we've looked at
actually should we go after building um
relationships with with health
colleagues and I think what we've
recognized is we we should stick to what
we know and our our business is is
Council Council spend Council
procurement that doesn't prevent us from
actually doing collaborative work um we
have the ccg's clinical commissioning
groups and as they used to be known
we've done many multipartner
procurements where we've done it for 10
councils 10 ccgs so it's not a no-go
area just our Core Business is very much
focused on councils what I will say as I
spent Monday afternoon in a workshop
with the NHS talking about procurement
star social value and because they are
to be frank quite far behind on the
social value agenda and um we're
building some really good collaborative
relationships so who knows what we will
do jointly in the
future thank
[Music]
you percent Target you just you know
keep priorities and
also
savings thank you three more very
exceptional questions I'll try and do my
best to answer so in terms of targets we
do have a local SP spend targeters a
star family um we are exceeding that
every year so what my drun committee
needs to do this time is actually up my
Target and push Push Me Harder on that
we've just been working with the team
this morning and what we've seen is that
the wiggly line has started to sort of
plateau so what we need to say is well
business as usual is lovely but actually
we need more and what action are we
going to create and what plan are we
going to build into our new strategy
from this year to actually move that
performance onwards because that's the
way we learn and grow by being put under
a little bit of pressure and actually
thinking about how can we do something
differently to change that direction um
in terms of the the procurement act that
that is coming out this year um social
value isn't explicit in the
act right or wrong we could probably
have a view but we're not going to
because we're we're not in the position
of of privilege in terms of helping
although we have both been working
nationally on some working groups that
have developed that over time what we
did have was the national procurement
policy statement that as I say was
launched in 2021 that is more explicit
about the requirements of social value
we have the social value act that was um
launched launched in 2012
2013 um that as yet hasn't been
refreshed we are over 10 years from the
the part of that act being launched um
and sadly at the time it used the
language around consider social value
and it wasn't mandated I had my magic W
dad put the mandated word in and say you
know if we can do it in Star everybody
should be doing it because it is
definitely giving a return in terms of
that added value um there are things
embedded and woven within the ACT which
is is actually putting emphasis on local
spend there are facilities within the
new act that will allow us to ring fence
and Target um local businesses which
wasn't there before so there are things
within there that will actually enable
us to move more more closely in terms of
diversity of businesses looking at how
we ring fans and Target local businesses
um so there are things that we we can do
I think that will enable us to show some
improvement but we do sometimes sit a
little bit smugly to think we we've
actually already tried and tested some
of this within star are but that doesn't
prevent us from seeing how how far we
can push it further um and I think your
final question counselor is is really
important I'm going to look down at Gram
now as as your um Finance director um
how do we balance the cost of social
value um I think over the last certainly
almost five years where we've really
gone with great Vigor and to put social
value into the procurement process one
of the issues I've had and and certainly
officers have challenged me on is to say
are we paying for social value because
if a bidder is offering you know the
world of you things in their contract um
are they sticking an extra note on the
price um I think the answer I've given
historically is while whilst I can't
prove or disprove that what I have done
I did an analysis over um I won't name
which Council but one of the star
councils and it wasn't yours and I did
an analysis of 16 contracts and we
actually said if we' actually awarded
without social value or with social
value what would be the differential and
and the slight slight increase of price
on some of those contracts not all of
those contracts was way outweighed by
the added value that came from social
value so for me I am the chair of the
national social value task force my tag
just declare so I do have an interest
here to push this agender nationally but
for me social value is absolutely the
right thing that all public sector
bodies should be doing but I think that
needs to be more creative as we move
forward I think it needs to be more
bespoke as we're using um something
called things outcomes and measures to
at the moment and which is a national
sort of off the shelf approach what I
want to do and and Elizabeth's working
hard on this with Trafford is to make
our approach to social value more
bespoke because you as counselors will
want things to happen in particular
Wards because of of deprivation and
priority you will want things to happen
with particular cohorts of of people
within your communities because they may
Bel long to unemployed they may be ex
offenders and there may be some really
targeted work that I think we can Ena
through procurement by actually working
more closely with with Trafford and
actually making that more a bespoke
approach I also think um there is
another piece of work that we need to
actually value what a bid it brings on
day one when they're actually bidding
because there is some inherent social
value particularly in our our um
volunteering Community SE organizations
that we don't actually take account of
and take regard of at present and I
think we should be rewarding them and
valuing what they do because they
practice what they preach and terms of
social value because they are a social
business and I think we should be clever
of rewarding and valuing what they bring
um biders who have real Liv and wage
accreditation biders who are signing up
to the um good employment Charter
supporters I think for me these are the
biders that we should actually be
opening and letting go of the threshold
to actually tender for all contracts
because they're practicing the values
that you want us to to deploy as a
council hope that's answered
Prof
walon thank you it's really interesting
um first one first question may be a bit
naive of me to ask this
but I presume that the one anything that
the one traffic partnership does is
separate from this and then of the sub
subcontracting and that never never
comes to you I presume and do you have
any thoughts on on how one TR
partnership does things um the second
question is much more spe specific um
obviously a lot of the you know lot of
this um procurement that we're doing
will result in vehicle Journeys and that
kind of thing whether it's delivering
something or somebody making a journey
um do we ask for standards of driver
behavior um you know looking at
requiring you know saying we don't want
contractors or suppliers who are going
to be you know payment parking IL
legally you know speeding on our streets
um you know do they do we ask if they
have black boxes in their vehicles to
monitor driver behavior and are they
running dash cams to you know so they
can to again monitor Drive Behavior also
so they can report incidents if they see
them on you know on our streets so two
very different
questions yeah I'll answer for the first
one H so in terms of the one traffic
partnership we're available for advice
and guidance um we do get involved when
when we're asked to get involved um and
not when we're not so um yeah I I don't
have a view on how they do things um but
yeah so we we're we're part of Trafford
so um any any procurement advice and
guidance needed we you know we're happy
to
deliver do you get asked for we we are
yeah yeah we do get involved yeah so um
in the main we we split between three
categories people plac and professional
so in the main that sits within within
the place category um so I'm not closely
linked to it it's one of our heads of
service Michael uh that would be
involved world that would have more
information if you needed more
information I could get that for you
yeah all right thank you thanks
Elizabeth um and in terms of behaviors
when we build um a specification and go
out to Market we we obviously that comes
from the service department and what we
call them their subject matter experts
because our profession is procurement
social value and obviously um doing all
the the magic that we do so the Reliance
is very much on um the the offices
within those client departments to
actually build things in that they
require so um obviously we're passionate
about the regional priorities and
looking at Carbon and that sort of thing
but the specification in terms of going
down to the detail around black boxes
and um driving you know in good behavior
it can be built in there's no reason why
it can't be built in and that could be a
contractual requirement but it's not
something that we push for what we will
do is if we've got good Exemplar work
from other councils where we've seen um
good practice in the tender
documentation we always pinch things
because the best ideas are always stolen
so we will learn from colleagues and you
know one of the benefits of working
collaboratively and and now you know
multi- regionally um is that we we share
that learning both you know in terms of
our good stuff but equally we we learn
from other people as well so it can be
built in it's not a no um but it we tend
to focus on the things that that are
either in social value in terms of those
things outcomes and measures and in
terms of the GM um actual priorities
around social value as
well you ever seen such a thing in a in
a contract know we need to tell our
officers that that's what we want um
we've never never I don't think we've
ever asked for a black box in in one of
our tenders so um but you know you never
know it depends on um what the client
wants you know in terms of their
specifications so uh but no we've not
seen that yet
yet that's the thank you first of all
just want to say I think we can all be
very proud of of the this
organization uh fairly unique setting up
and also the uh the way it's progressed
tremendously and another the rum as and
and your organization there you know
management side it's uh it's been very
respectful and uh picked up a lot of
Accolade uh and people are showing
authorities are showing it with their
feet I wanted to get involved so much so
it's something that's become hugely
successful I think we as a traffic
Council very proud of this
organization um the other thing I wanted
to mention uh is I'm the chair of the
health scrutiny committee at traford and
I was just wondering and it just touches
on Council boards mentioned it as well
uh is the the work that you do uh in
terms of procurement within the NHS
aspect think the organizations involved
in and i' very much love for you to be
coming to our next meeting with maybe a
small presentation or something with the
what your how your work impacts on the
NHS you know we've got the new
integrated care system uh linking in
with the uh Le of Manchester and there's
huge opportunities obviously there but
we from a traffic point of view uh from
the health perspective how you are
impacting on our work and what what
you've got you know coming up in the
future and what organizations perhaps
you might you know that you're dealing
with and how you how you operate there
uh so if you could certainly plug in it
to a certain extent but if we could have
that as an agenda for our organiz yeah
more more than happy and CH to to attend
um to any any event that you wishes we
we've got you know a strong team it's
not just m and Elizabeth so you know
we're more than happy to come and talk
to anybody and as I say I was actually a
workshop on Monday afternoon so Richard
Lee was there and opening the event and
CLA do was there from cabinet office so
you know pleas please invite us and
include us we we'll share what we do you
know happy to facilitate and help
thinking in in the health sector as well
what we can I'll be interested thank you
thank you anybody
else well I think that's it I just thank
you ladies for the presentation just c b
said at the end there I mean you've been
coming here seems like
years seems Seems longer to you me but
you know it's quite right you know over
the years it's got not bigger and bigger
but better better isn't it so hopefully
next year my ageold Ru to say I'll see
you next year but hopefully we'll we'll
see you again we'll be even bigger and
betterday thanks very much
very okay so we go on to item eight the
audit progress report which is alist
you're doing it
m thank you chair yes uh FAL update from
me for this meeting rather than a
written report and and relatively brief
um I was hoping the um we're expecting a
consultation from the Department of
leveling up he and communities on the
arrangements for the um what's being
known as the back stop Arrangements in
terms of audit for 223 and earlier years
and I was hoping that was going to be
published um in time for this meeting so
I could brief members on the content of
it but it hasn't yet yet be um so I'm
I'm largely in the dark and what I'm
proposing is that when that consultation
comes out I'll have conversations with
gram to understand the impact um on the
audit and uh how we'll take that forward
and then I'll come back and brief you at
a subsequent meeting I I strongly hope
certainly hope that that's in time for
your March meeting um if it isn't then
I've got a fairly significant problem
that's um not of my making um the two
things that I do know that I can share
with you is that um and that this is in
the public domain is that there is a
date Beyond which Auditors won't be able
to do work on 22 23 and earlier years
and that's going to be the end of
September this year and so that is my
deadline date for completing the work on
the accounts um and reporting to you the
outcome of that work um and the second
element that is known is that our work
on your value for money Arrangements we
we have a requirement to do that every
year that is not changing um so my
priority now and the conversations I've
had with um the audit manager is to
progress that work for the current year
for your 23 24 year with a backward look
to 223 and enabling us to bring a report
to you um summarizing our views and the
commentary for both years trying to do
both years in one that might be a little
challenging and it might it might take a
little bit of discussion with you but
that's my plan as for the meeting that I
bring that to I can't definitively say
which one that would be it won't be for
your March meeting but it will be as
soon as possible recognizing that we
want to get reports to you on a timely
basis so I hope that's helpful obviously
happy to take any questions uh on
anything other than consultation and the
content
thanks any question
anybody no
can I just interested
INR don't think that's my
item my item is not in the report P
sorry sorry
yeah okay got
little than trying to answer a question
you wouldn't want my
answer yeah okay uh I mean we wait
information from the government really
don't wor about the last year's
audit new audit okay thanks very much
you had a wasted evening youve been
hopefully abely you've been sat there
all through our about cyber security and
so yeah okay well thanks very much you
can welcome to stay if you're so
inclined
yes yes
yes okay so we going to item uh
9 investment strategy which is uh is it
you gra that yeah I'll update um you've
obvious got my presentation as part of
your packs so I'm not not proposing to
run through it slide by slide I think
the reason we brought this here was
because of I think a question of the
last meeting around governance
particularly uh the role of Investment
Management board so there's some slides
there around around that which I'll just
cover off quickly in a minute I
think what we tried to just present in
the slides is the fact that we've had a
an investment strategy since
um and I think over that period the
strategies matured and developed from
from being one that invested
primarily in the early years in buying
physical
assets
um something that we couldn't do now
couldn't do that as part of the
strategy and and now the focus is
on that real focus on regeneration
meeting our Council priorities with the
secondary motive of trying to generate
an income Stream
So I think what what the investment
management board do is oversee the
delivery of that that strategy so we've
got a cross party group of
members um with the chief exec on that
and is supported by a group of officers
I'm on I'm on the board um to advise
that board of opportunities and I think
the role of the board as well as the
oversight is to
approve um investment opportunities that
come along
um that's done on a stage base
so we use investment advisors to in
effect Source opportunities and the
Board review those opportunities on a on
a staged basis so initially the
opportunity comes to the board does it
feel does it look right uh is it
achieving what we want to do is
it is it spreading our risk in terms of
a obviously we don't want to put all our
legs in one basket as part of the
strategy so making sure it's it's
Diversified within that strategy so
they'll get a stage one
report um if if if we like the feel of
that investment we will then do further
amount of due diligence using our
investment advisors um to do that final
due diligence before final Investments
are
approved
um I've I've put in the slides
around what commitments on page number
26 you'll see there
that what we've got at the moment is a
set of commitments that have been made
and approvals through the investment
management Board of just over 360
million pounds so this is probably when
you think the revenue budget in its
entirety is 200 million this is quite a
large area that we're trying to cover
off um you'll see that the details of
the property is that we bought on the
left hand side of that page but I think
what the focus is on now is really
around the provision of senior
development
debt um whereby
developers who need Finance to undertake
their developments approach us via our
investment man investment advisors to
borrow that money from us and we assess
those opportunities so you can see the
list of opportunities and investment
that we've got
there I think just
to look at the size of the fund as part
of the budget scrutiny work we we take
an assessment as to whether or not we
think the 500 million which is the
budget for this level of activities um
appropriate or not and we take that
through scrutiny as part of our budget
deliberations each year slide
28 uh I think is an interesting one in
terms of what is it delivering in
financial terms um since 2017 we've
achieved about 30 million pound of net
benefit to support our budget so it's
it's it's big and it's important um and
we want balancing Council budget without
it at this stage um you'll see there
that the gross income is about 15
million a year
broadly and obviously that's
covering um predominantly
the costs of our finance costs because
we've got to borrow money to
then passport that into the Investments
we're making so we'll cover all that off
we're still making between five and six
million pound a year um to mitigate
risks there's quite a lot of work done
in terms of um risk around the
strategies you can imagine it's that big
there's a lot of risks um and we
maintain a risk Reserve that we keep on
the balance sheet
um in the event of
fluctuations
um and whether or not for example we we
have to invest in a property for example
if there is a change of tency we may
have to invest in the property in the
future so we accumulated a risk reserve
for for issues like that and also to
some extent for periods when we can't
maintain the level of income we're
currently doing because there may be
downtime between getting
an investment we paid and then make him
um a new
investment in terms of transparency on
page 29 I think what we try to do is is
maintain that transparency so when we do
our budget monitor reports we include
updates in terms of the commitments
we've made and the returns we're getting
um in terms of our report on our
valuation work that goes in our
statement of
accounts um so
I think it's fair to say we it's just
keeping that transparency of what we're
doing I think is key for all members and
it's not just the investment management
board because it's that much of a big
part of our Revenue
budget um the last slide on slide 30
just details the different types of risk
um work that we do in terms of um
looking at valuation risks looking at
market and sector risks and obviously
that informs our strategy
um going forward so bit of a Whistle
Stop T but I'm happy to take any
questions or if there's any aspects of
it we want to bring back to Future
meetings again more than happy to do
that but like I said it was really
brought back just to focus a little bit
on the governance of the investment
management
board thanks very much any
questions
surprise I
think I should have added at the start
our investment strategies is agreed
every year by Council and I think one of
the things that we're keen to doing is
where we
can one invest in things that cover our
key priorities and also we have what we
call or what we call consider our key
attributes one of them is green um and
sustainability benefits so it's it's one
of the things that we look at as part of
any investment opportunity we've got
nothing specific in terms of direct
green infrastructure ones that we're
looking at at the
moment yeah
sorry
might the green infrastructure loans
yeah
there's nothing we've got at the moment
you say the strategies are being
explored so can we have an example of
what
might might we be doing or what are
other other councils
doing I sounds sounds you know like a
nice aspiration but I think we'd all
like to hear what it might look like in
practice I think it is aspirational and
I think that's probably something we'll
bring back to the investment management
board as part of developing the strategy
that we've got
yeah I mean it's been around this has
been around for a while and the and the
the idea of using this has been around
for a while so really is time that it's
bit more would you agree that it's time
that we were a bit more concrete about
this either either if we can use it for
that we should have an idea of what
we're going to do or we should just say
we're not going to use it rather than
kind of greenwashing our investment
strategy slightly by saying that it
might be used by useful for this in
future years is that that be fair I
think it is I think
we we're open to
opportunities but I think it's at the
end of the day it's that viability of
that opportunity whether it's
sustainable not and I think whilst we
have pulled that down and I've
considered you you hear about solar
farms for
example is that a viable approach we've
not we've not come across one yet or
else it will be part more the direct
thing would would have seen that through
the investment management board but
we've not had that
opportunity I as I raised with you
before there is a difference between
investing in a social solar farm
somewhere else and investing in solar
panels for as many schools in traford as
we can put them on that has a you know
would probably have a return given that
there is a return in these projects on
schools it's been proved at Wellington
where they're putting a th000 panels on
at the moment and there's return to the
schools in terms of saving themselves
you know energy which you know which is
um you know another plus as well so you
know the there are there a different
very different types of projects and
there there are other councils that are
pursuing these things and we're not so I
think the SE I think um we've obviously
developed
our carbon reduction team in Richard RS
area and I think there are opportuni
that we're looking at particularly where
you mentioned the schools and the solar
panels um but that's just something
we're assessing at the
moment thanks any anything
else thanks very much thanks gr for that
we'll go on to the next item which is uh
the U treasury management report you
have your
friend yes it is thank you
chair uh so this is the uh strategy
which sets out the
council's uh plans for funding its
capital program over the next three
years and its policies for investing any
cash
balances um this strategy requires
approval by Council prior to its
implementation next
year um there's certain Elements which
specifically require approval including
the debt strategy investment strategy
policy on M p and prenal indicators and
limits um the key items to note would be
the U the debt forecast is is forast to
increase from 303 million at the end of
2023 to 547 Million by the end of the
three-year period this is uh reflective
of the uh council's spending plans of
the next three years in addition to uh
plan to reduce the underbarrow that's
been carried forth from previous periods
which we discussed at the mid year
report um the other item would be the
the investment Str has been amended from
previous years to uh bring in a policy
of only investing in financial
institutions which are signaries to the
UN principles for responsible banking uh
this just allows the council some conf
that it cash its cash is being invested
into institutions with a reasonable ESG
standing um
following this
filtering the investment policy would
revert to the uh SL as previously
prioritized which is security Reis yield
which is still the requirement on the
statute um that's it any questions on
that thanks
CH any
questions no Frank you got away with
that thanks very much get away with
probably inappropriate but
you've got a very good report thank you
thanks okay we go on to item uh 11
budget monitoring period 8 that uh is
new gra is it yeah it is um this is the
the report that went to exec at the end
of January so again quite timely and I
think quite positive in terms of um
where the outter projection has moved to
so we we're projecting underspend on
budgeted .6
million um a movement from period six of
just over a million um it's fair to say
that we have introduced management
action particularly around trying to
control
vacancies um during the year because
what we've been trying to
avoid um and I know we're not out of the
woods yet because this is only period
eight
but if we could avoid that over spend
position at year and it avoids any
unnecessary use of reserves reserves for
Trafford the law and so we don't want to
use them
unnecessarily so in terms of this
projection at the moment is positive in
that sense we are carrying a number of
underlying under over spends par
particularly on children's
services uh which is over3 million pound
projected overspend at year end I think
and that's what's been one of the
challenges in terms of setting the 245
budget um in that obviously we've had to
build the impacts of that the full year
impacts of that into
um I think as we move through the report
I think what we're seeing and it's it's
offsetting um some of our service we've
got overall a C Net service underspend
of about two
million part of that's been offset by a
pressure of got on business rates income
and a lot of that has to do with timings
of when new facilities new shops new
premises open i s the big one around
Marks and Spencers in the Trafford
Center that can delay income and that
puts a pressure on our budget monitor
until we receive that income um in terms
of delivery of savings
programs uh we've got nearly 12 million
pound of savings program for 234 we're
delivering uh 99% that which I think is
quite remarkable when you think the
amount of years that we've been
delivering
savings
um one of the issues that we seen
develop which is quite a
significant issue in terms of the
financial size of the problem is on our
schools budgets and high needs we're
projecting a deficit on our high needs
budget um of about 7 million pound this
year
which will mean at the year end we've
got accumulative deficit on that budget
of about 10 and in terms of the budget
reports we've done when we projected
that on that broadly jumps by 10 million
pounds per year so at the moment when we
look at our Council reserves yes we've
got some reserves but not many I've got
what we call a deficit Reserve an
overdrawn reserve on high needs that is
getting to a really significant figure
and I think the B imp to how we work
with DFE because the DFE are working
with some authorities but those
authorities are in much D need be
interested in knowing what that
threshold is we've got a meeting with
them as to when our need becomes diet
and DFE when they start helping us out
um but that's just a growing problem
it's not I keep said at these meetings
not just Trafford but when you talk
about finances when we talk about
treasury management it's it's it's
consuming cash
um that we're trying to manage in in our
day-to-day treasury functions as well so
I think I'll conclude at that point just
to say I think period positive movement
but we still got obviously third of the
Year still to report
on than any
questions
bro SC
back just scrolling back to your
headline figures
and you mentioned
the red for the Children's Service and I
can see that on the report um but in the
green you've got Adult Services by quite
a considerable amount so I'm just
wondering what it is that I mean we all
know local is a lot of pressure for
Adult Services so what is it there
that's made that big green amount com to
services
please I think a couple of points i'
just like to bring up is the fact that
each and every
year government have been given quite
significant amount of grant funding
specifically for
adults so that's one thing that he's
probably seeing that actually the
position on adults was more favorable
than
children the other thing that got
announced and it was a part year
announcement was some additional Grant
around what they called Market
sustainability funding so we've been
able to manage some of that to the
benefit of our inye budget position was
an unforeseen Grant at the start of the
year so I think there's a combination of
things that
um have led to that position being in
that green zone at the moment that's not
to say there aren't pressures on I
social care cost there are but I think
when we set budgets every year we've
seen seen that there's been an not an
influx of funding but additional funding
to help mitigate those pressures more so
than what we've seen on the children's
side
okay I was just wondering
about
delay may not sustainable the outcome
might
about home school transport I
mean you thinkwork
transport mostly children would be able
to use
buses I think on that latter point I
think the answer is yes I'm more than
happy to take that back ask that
question but obviously
it's the demand
on high
needs and the the pressure we've got on
that high needs budget is is in effect
the cost of the educational aspects the
cost of the transport aspects for those
children rests on our general
fund
so I I don't think it would have a
massive effect that's not what we' seen
through the projections it's not what
when we've done the robustness we're not
seeing that coming out to say we may
have potential gain that I think not I
think the the
Staffing position on budget is a concern
um we're really Keen I think
to obviously we've got Front Line
Service delivery if we've got vacancies
we've got agency costs so the positions
within this report is still the net
position having taken account of agency
costs um I just think turnover and staff
recruitement in local government is a
national issue and I think it I think it
affects all service areas that's that's
not to
say recruitment control that we do
operate because we had to operate it to
try to control if you remember the early
part of the financial year we were
reporting some over spends we've tried
toil some of that with sub recruitment
control but that's mainly around back
office not front line and and we in some
areas pose recruitment where we can
where we think there's not going to be a
front line um service impact and that
purely to control expenditure of the
resource we've
got counc
L yeah can I ask about ask house in the
Intermediate Care
Service and as far as I can see
from this that we again the full cost
from Manchester Foundation trust how can
we Rec that money because it's a loss
towards we can't afford the loss
really really good question and I think
it's fair to say it's been challenging
us probably for the last 12 months and
and that dialogue with the Manchester
Foundation trust who in effect pay the
local Care Organization who pay pay us
they not paying us enough we've got an
ongoing dialogue as to how we resolve
that um and it's it's fair to say it's a
really difficult position um I think
what we're trying to do is manage it um
within our overall resources we've got
we've got budget for what we call
discharge to
assess so where people where we have to
keep that flow of people coming out of
Hospital we're trying to manage that
position position at the moment until
we've got a resolution with mft from
within those budget areas to avoid it
being a hit on our bottom line um it's
not satisfactory at the
moment okay
Jud yeah I just wondering about the U
the loss on um planning income um I know
there's been some
changes from the central government to
enable us is it charge Market you know
the actual cost of what planning um
planning applications cost us to process
is that correct and is that likely to
mean that that that turns around that
that deficit in planning
income I think I think the technical
side have to take back to Richard I do
know we have got a pressure on planning
income I think a lot of that's because
of state of the market the speed that
some of the large planning applic
appliations are coming forward because I
think it's the large planning
applications that give us the the large
amounts of income to support budget so I
think we've seen a delay on those in
terms of the specifics around changes in
planning income and and what we charge I
think that's something I'll just take
away I do know with the inar pressure
we're seeing here we have built it into
budget planning but not at the scale
because I think Richard said there has
been some sort of free uplifts that will
part mitigate of the pressures that we
seeing this
year okay anything else no thanks very
much thanks for that we go on to item 12
audit Insurance Service up dat report
which is
Mark just take the main points in terms
work completed between October and
December um continuing to progress the
plan um focusing the quarter and of
audits as Financial systems service
related aits including schools as well
um terms of the key outcomes um in
section four
um page 14 there just highlights six
final audit reports issued um three of
which are the highest opinion
substantial and then the second level
reasonable three other orits
um section five the next page covers the
individual aits there um see in terms of
the financial system
reviews accounts P purchase cards and
included elements follow in those
reviews um but also the findings
acknowledge developments planed over the
next 12 to Chang the systems as well
upgrades we
get F in 245 plan to see those
improvements
Contin um other reviews with substantial
Assurance around safety exports grounds
in terms of me our procedures so looking
at the procedures we've got in place
Council and also the cleaning service
cleaning services with instruct
resources um
look at their financial management
control Performance Management
arrangements and also a couple of school
audits where we issued final reports
where overall um effed controls in place
there was some
recommendations
primary um there were also some draft
reports and we'll I'll report on those
in in the course for updates um and also
we did some work around a requirement
for us to look at the disabled
facilities Grant each year to to help in
terms of the sign off of that to
demonstrate with theur expend terms of
so we
October we also did some work Star as an
advisory report around their processes
in respect
ofur section six just covers other areas
of work as well as the main audit report
um there's an update there around our
national for
initiative involvement where we've
coordinating role really um and working
with other
services around data matching um
particularly in terms of outcomes the
the council's coun team um identified
them around Council at support um well
not great great value in things but a
few individual claims been corrected the
work is still ongoing so in terms of the
annual a report in June we'll have
further outcomes from that work
from just in terms of feedback on on
audit work from Services October to
December all the individual
recommendations been accepted by
management
um follow those up progress going
forward um in terms of the followup work
we did um overall see the chart there's
good progress in terms of implementation
of a recommendations good proportion
I've been
implemented um any reviews where there's
still some outstanding that would be
more for work as part
24 uh in terms of just where we're to
Performance wise in terms of our
um we've got 30 reports or assments for
the year 23 December we're pretty well
on track meet that
time the head June get full details the
whole year um so just thinking in terms
of the work for the current cour in um
there'll be a number of final reports
section
to issue I also bring the plan for
245 uh to the committee the next meeting
as well we'll also be commencing a
recruitment exercise later in the
quarter as well from part
team one there just gives a summary
terms of pie of work
stat um any reviews that haven't started
or only just started will make sure we
those as
well
of
question information but I can't
actually see the colors on my screen you
know the I did raise this last time
about the colors but everything's black
and white so actually I look at that I I
I I know because it's light green dark
green Amber and red but all I can see is
very Shades of
Gray yeah for all of it I'm just
wondering where the colors are but yeah
but on the report it doesn't seem to be
reflected in in report colors maybe it's
just all black and white
um yeah I'm just looking where is
where
is it
sectionid let's find section five yeah
there are there are colors so where
we've actually
given that's it so I I I think I've been
distracted by the purple
on very color orientated person but yeah
I think when you see V ratings they
really do help you grasp a situation
quickly in a very detailed report so I'm
glad you change the calls but I was just
looking back I couldn't actually see any
red anywhere is that correct
not yeah yeah okay thank
you
questions thank very much we go on to
item 13 12 13 accounts the work
program yeah just fin in terms of the
work program obviously one more meeting
for the year in March that just now
include strategic
risk one of those risk clate
emergency on
that yeah just on the climate emergency
I think this came up in some early
meetings I was part and it was all about
somebody new in post being embedded in
that post will the presentation be by
that the new person in post or will it
be yeah think started
January okay any further
questions right well we come to there no
urgent business that I'm aware of
no thank you no thanks very much no
confidential business because we dealt
with that early on the meeting okay
thanks very much everybody for your
attendance those who stayed didn't have
to
do thanks
bye